appel karins beauty und ein reisestopp
klappt hallo leute immer wieder kriege
ich freien von euch die post vom bafa
nach oberhausen
wer wollte ich wissen aktuell würde
eigentlich noch nach amerika fliegen
auch hierbei breites kreuz du sparst
gute frage aber in jedem fall sommer
gerade jetzt erst recht nur auf eines
muss man unbedingt achten bei der
einreise so freundlich gucken wie du
kannst wenn mich der fallmanager drüben
dann fragt was ist der zweck ihrer reise
dann sage ich spaß und entspannung
und wenn er dann fragt haben die
lebensmittel auf europa dabei immer
sagen nein natürlich nicht mal weisen
nur wegen trump wegen einem orangen oper
nicht in die usa reisen
das ist auch wartet muss alles tun so
als wäre für hitler
aber ganz ehrlich was hat er denn bis
jetzt erreicht gar nichts er hat im
japanischen premierminister den arm
gebrochen
guckt man hier erleichtert der kleine
bahnhof luft und sonne hat es geschafft
für nur drei wochenenden mit seiner
familie in florida zehn millionen dollar
steuergeld raus brown
und was pro stunde für haarspray drauf
geht weiter
die usa sind nächstes jahr also lieber
jetzt nochmal hinfliegen und für alle
die so aussehen wie ich also wie ein
klassischer bielefelder hier noch mal
einfach zu reinigen hilft für die
einreise um weniger bedrohlich zu wirken
reicht von mir auch wenn ich die haare
nach vorne käme schließlich ganz anderer
eindruck und wer ganz sicher gehen will
wo kommt ihr auf jeden fall rein um beim
nächsten mal zeige ich euch niemals in
den jemen ein reifen am besten gar nicht
[Applaus]